since it's 4:20
hi my name is Lynn root I am a software
engineer here at Spotify now I'll be the
first to admit that I often take for
granted the reliability of the Internet
the sheer amount of information zooming
around the Internet is astonishing how
is it possible for every piece of data
to be delivered to you reliably say you
want to play a song from Spotify it
seems like your computer connects
directly to Spotify servers and Spotify
sends you a song on a direct dedicated
line but actually that's not how the
internet works if the internet were made
of direct dedicated connections it would
be impossible to keep things working as
millions of users join especially since
there's no guarantee that every wire and
computer is working all the time instead
data travels on the Internet in a much
less direct fashion many many years ago
in the early 1970s my partner Bob Kahn
and I began working on the design of
what we now call the Internet Bob and I
had the responsibility and the
opportunity to design the Internet's
protocols and its architecture so we
persisted in participating in the
Internet's growth and evolution for all
of this time up to and including the
present the way information gets
transferred from one computer to another
is pretty interesting it need not follow
a fixed path in fact your path may
change in the midst of a computer to
computer conversation information on the
internet goes from one computer to
another in what we call a packet of
information and a packet travels one
place to another on the Internet a lot
like how you might get from one place to
another in a car depending on traffic
congestion or road conditions you might
choose or be forced to take a different
route to get to the same place each time
you travel and just as you can transport
all sorts of stuff inside a car many
kinds of digital information can be sent
with IP packets but there are some
limits what if for example you need to
move a space shuttle from where it was
built to where it will be launched the
shuttle won't fit in one truck so it
needs to be broken down into pieces
transported using a fleet of trucks they
could all take different routes
and might get to the destination at
different times but once all the pieces
are there you can reassemble the pieces
into the complete shuttle and it will be
ready for launch on the internet the
details work similarly if you have a
very large image that you want to send
to a friend or upload to a website that
image might be made up of tens of
billions of bits or ones and zeros too
many descent long in one packet since
its data on a computer the computer
sending the image can quickly break it
into hundreds or even thousands of
smaller parts called packets unlike cars
or trucks these packets don't have
drivers and they don't choose their
route each packet has the internet
address of where it came from and where
it's going special computers on the
internet called routers act like traffic
managers to keep the packets moving
through the networks smoothly if one
route is congested individual packets
may travel different routes through the
internet and they may arrive at the
destination at slightly different times
or even out of order so let's talk about
how this works as part of the Internet
Protocol every router keeps track of
multiple paths for sending packets and
it chooses the cheapest available path
for each piece of data based on
destination IP address for the packet
cheapest in this case doesn't mean cost
but time and non-technical factors such
as politics and relationships between
companies often the best route for data
to travel isn't necessarily the most
direct having options for paths makes
the network fault tolerant which means
the network can keep sending packets
even if something goes horribly horribly
wrong this is the basis for a key
principle of the internet liability now
what if you want to request some data
and not everything is delivered so you
want to listen to a song how can you be
100 percent sure all the data will be
delivered so the song plays perfectly
introducing your new best friend TCP
transmission control protocol TCP
manages the sending and receiving of all
your data as packets think of it like a
guaranteed mail service when you request
a song on your device Spotify sends a
song broken up into many packets
when your packets arrived TCP does a
full inventory and sends back
acknowledgments of each packet received
if all packets are there TCP signs for
your delivery and you're done if TCP
finds some packets are missing it won't
sign otherwise your song would sound as
good or portions of the song could be
missing for each missing or incomplete
packet Spotify will resend them once TCP
verifies the delivery of many packets
for that one song request your song will
start to play what's great about the TCP
and router systems is they're scalable
they can work with 8 devices or 8
billion devices in fact because of these
principles of fault tolerance and
redundancy the more routers we add the
more reliable the Internet becomes
what's also great is we can grow and
scale the internet without interrupting
service for anybody using it the
internet is made of hundreds of
thousands of networks and billions of
computers and devices connected
physically these different systems that
make up the Internet connect to each
other communicate with each other and
work together because of agreed-upon
standards for how data is sent around on
the Internet
computing devices or routers along the
Internet help all the packets make their
way to the destination where they're
reassembled if necessary in order this
happens billions of times a day whether
you and others are sending an email
visiting a webpage doing a video chat
using a mobile app or when sensors or
devices on the Internet talk to each
other
you